Speaker 1: Mike Pence malfunctioned at a
completely cringeworthy town hall on CNN last
night. This is absolutely beyond belief. Former
Vice President Mike Pence had a really bad town
hall on CNN last night in which he, among other
things, got a lady's name wrong and then just went
silent for 5 seconds. It really, really odd. The
the bigger question is why he's even doing town
halls on CNN right now. You might say, well, it's
because he's maybe running in 24, maybe right now.
The predictive markets don't look very good for
Mike Pence. So check out this clip. This is one of
the wildest clips I've seen. A lady named Andrea
asks a question. And Pence call. Pence calls her
Barbara. And then it gets really weird and Pence
appears to malfunction. Now, I admit I watched
this about ten times last night. I was laughing
so hard to myself. I almost woke up my sleeping
baby daughter. Check this out. Now, the Andrea's
last name is Barber Dansby. So Barbara wasn't
completely pulled out of thin air. But her name
isn't Barbara. It's Andrea. When Andrea corrects
Mike Pence, he sort of seems to freeze and
glitch. It was almost Trump like. Check this out.
Speaker 2: This freedom based on Roe
also continue. Barbara, thank you.
I represented madison county in congress for
many years. Andrea, it's nice to see you. Well.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1:
That that pause was not. I did I did nothing
to doctor that very, very strange pause.
This is a Kafkaesque moment. I know, I know.
It's been months since I brought out Kafkaesque.
This is unbelievable. Barbara, thank you. The
my name is Andrea. Good to see you. And then
he says nothing. I let's just just take it in
one more time for its full cringeworthy glory.
Speaker 2: And this freedom. Based on
Roe, also continue. Barbara, thank you.
I represented Madison County in Congress for
many years. Andrea, it's nice to see you.
You know, when I.
Speaker 1: Oh, dear God. Okay. So it was
only downhill from there, if you can imagine. That
wasn't even the worst moment. So the first actual
question that Pence got, it was such a softball
that I thought this was all going to be a waste of
time. Look. Look at how soft this question is.
Speaker 2: Whether you love him or hate him.
Yeah. Former President Trump, now
candidate Trump is a polarizing
figure who brought controversial issues
to the forefront of American politics.
How does the country move past the polarization
and find common ground solutions to these
important issues facing this nation?
Speaker 1: I mean, Pence's answer doesn't
even matter. That's the prototypical softball
question. And of course, Pence has no idea how
to bring the country together. He's part of
the evangelical right wing movement that has
so division in the country for decades. Pence is
completely unqualified to answer the question,
but so soft. But then it actually got kind of
interesting. CNN actually showed video showed
Pence video of the gallows where Trump supporters
wanted to hang Pence on January six. Now,
Pence has developed a sort of demeanor during
these moments where he will sort of like pause
and act like he's thinking very deeply. And
it's very, you know, important what to say.
It's all contrived, but it's still interesting
to confront him with this video. Check this out.
Speaker 2: Want to take you back to that day. Take
a look at the video over here. You know, that,
of course, was the news hanging outside the
Capitol that day and rioters were calling for your
execution, chanting Hang Mike Pence. Almost two
years later, is it still tough to hear some of the
video of the hanging Mike Pence? Two years later,
is it still tough to see that and hear that?
It's thinking that. Jake, it saddens me.
Speaker 1: Sad.
Speaker 2: But that day it angered
me. Yeah. I must tell you when.
When the Secret Service took us down to
the loading dock, accompanied by my wife,
my daughter, Charlotte, and our Secret Service
detail, I was determined to stay at my post. I.
Told the Secret Service that I was not
leaving the capital. I didn't want to give
those people the sight of a 16 car motorcade
speeding away from the Capitol that day.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2:
But frankly, when I saw those images and when
when I read a tweet that President Trump issued
saying that I lacked courage in that moment,
it angered me greatly. But to be honest
with you, I didn't have time for it. Yeah.
Speaker 1: It's all just very
strange. And I get the idea.
That what Pence is trying to do here is sort of
like project strength and calm and an unwavering
demeanor. But at the same time, it all continues
to be sort of like you realize the guy you worked
for almost got you killed, right? I mean, that
literally almost in the sense that, of course, he
had Secret Service protection, but his followers
wanted you dead. It wasn't Democrats. This was
your side. And then at another point, the town
hall almost gets like an intervention type vibe.
Speaker 2: If I were you, I would still be
livid with Donald Trump. I would be so furious.
And I know you're a measured man,
right? But are you still angry?
Well, I must tell you, the president's
words and tweet that day were reckless.
They endangered my family and.
And all the people at the Capitol.
And I was angry. But you know, my Christian
faith tells me to be quick to listen,
slow to speak, and slow to become angry.
Speaker 1: All right. So then he just
goes into Christian stuff and says, you know, we
forgive and so on and so forth. So the question,
why was he doing this at all? I don't really
know the answer. The betting markets now on the
question of who will win the 2024 Republican
nomination, have this. Quite frankly,
it's just a race between Ron DeSantis and Donald
Trump. And Mike Pence is sort of like an A tied
for third position alongside Nikki Haley and
Glenn Youngkin. So what this means for the
future of Pence, I don't really know. But it was
certainly interesting to hear where his head was
yesterday. And it's all very, very strange and
remains to be seen whether Pence will actually
run. But very, very he's just a strange
guy. I think at the end of the of the days,
what I'm realizing. He also appeared on Fox News.
Let's take a look at that appearance real quick